salut brut ces médias est confiné quoi
j'en ai profité pour me lancer dans la
musique
du coup je comprends qu'on prenait un
max tu vois je me suis longtemps pas
senti à ma place et tout ça mais c'est
moi là bas j'étais bien dans mes pompes
en fait c'est vraiment la société autour
qui m'a bousculé nous enlève alors je
crois que tu as un problème alors que
moi là bas j'étais bien le basket est en
fait c'est vraiment les gens qui vont
prendre conscience qu'il n'était pas
apte à placer que t'es pas dans le bon
ou les lectures encore dans les codes
moi très jeune déjà j'ai trouvé que je
savais que j'étais un peu différent
j'étais timide
jetez plus grosse que les autres
boulotte et où j'avais des lunettes je
me suis dit mohammad a ouvert on va
analyser cette situation c'est pas grave
vient on pleure pas on pleurera plus
tard chez le psy dans 10 ans 15 ans mais
l'avion on analyse ça de manière très
formelle viens tu vas tu ottomane et
avant qu'on te fasse des vannes et en
fait c'est comme ça que j'ai commencé à
développer cet avion pour la vanne
l'humour et l'autodérision pour elle
c'est simple à la base je suis la petite
soeur de la musique d'eric et ramzy ont
prévenu les pas du tout que je fasse ce
métier où je me tourne vers ça parce que
parce que j'étais assez doué à l'école
mon frère il est devenu humoriste très
connue d'un coup on était à
gennevilliers aux luttes qui était une
seat on est passé d'une cité à un
pavillon
je m'étais inscrite au théâtre g mais
vachement théâtre mais je n'ai pas trop
le dire tu vois et en même temps il y
avait un radis qui avait réussi alors
qu'ils n'avaient pas affecté a donc ça
voulait rien dire tu vois et un jour
j'ai mon bac
diam's et une pote de ma soeur à la base
et elle vient dimanche vous jure c'est
vrai à asnières-sur-seine manger le
couscous et ma grand mère dit il manque
des merguez je vais acheter des merguez
avec diable à asnières place des
bourguignons exactement où j'y vais et
en même temps je sortais avec elle parce
que comme je suis mais en cachette elle
ne l'aimé bien le sortir pour fumer une
clope ou de toi ok tu sors et à me dire
là tu vas faire quoi et tout d'un coup
je me suis inscrite à la sorbonne à la
fac en en elle elle sait que je crois
c'est un truc lorouër en anglais tu vois
en licence d'anglais et même dit à
vraiment universel
je sais pas quoi j'ai 16 piges valoir 17
ans je sais pas dans quel dit mais
pourquoi tu viendrais pas avec moi en
tournée je pars un an et demi il ya un
tour mus tu fais le stylisme l'habillage
thème bien les freins n'étaient pas plus
bête qu'une autre que tu admires
m'habiller entre les morceaux et tout ça
pour un concert charest trop bien et
tout ndiaye tu vas kiffer elle m'emmène
en tournée première date c'était à
angers au chabada et hamdi ben en fait
c'est pas mal tu vas faire les premières
parties aussi ginette quoi j'étais en
galère avec 400 millions d'euros mais
attends je comprends pas et m dit non
non on fait tu es drôle tu va l'assumer
et tu vas y aller j'y nom et comme josé
pas dire non même encore aujourd'hui je
sais pas dire non
je me suis retrouvé à ranger comme ça à
faire des blagues d'improvisation et a
essayé a duré pendant deux ans et c'est
là que j'ai commencé à prendre du
plaisir et à est à découvrir que
j'adorais l'impro j'ai adoré sur scène
j'ai adoré les faits alors je vomissais
avant j'y allais je courais après je
l'habille air france a été menée importe
quoi mais c'est beaucoup grâce à diam's
et après quand ramzy la suisse a il a
arrêté de me parler on a fait une petite
misère de grand frère un père protecteur
il voulait voir c'était une lubie ou si
tu es une vraie passion et j'ai jamais
lâché la sphère j'allais jouer dans des
petites salles et un producteur qui a
rentré qui m'anime élevé de produire
j'ai rien dit à mon frère j'ai signé un
contrat j'ai la plus dure est jeu signé
par intel et là il est tombé denim dit
continue tu vas voir et tout c'est
n'importe quoi qui a lu le contrat boom
a fait la misère mois pendant très
longtemps et même pour le dans
l'inconscient collectif on se dit oh là
là tu as une grosse qui va défiler une
grosse en couverture de magazine ça
n'existe pas moi la presse féminine je
la respecte plus depuis deux trois ans
parce que je me dis si j'ai des gens et
qui j'ai des échanges par avec des gens
de la mode et ça c'est les premiers à
dire attends on va être subversif on va
mettre de la techno et du rap pendant
les défilés de mode tu vas voir comme on
est en train de faire évoluer les choses
et dès qu'il s'agit de faire des vrais
trucs et de faire bouger le le vrai
problème il ya risible
ils ont peur encore la presse et mines
je lui en veux énormément parce qu'à
chaque fois que je passe devant un
kiosque
elle me fait ressentir moche peut pas
pas adapté à la société en fait et est
ce qui nous fait perdre confiance en
nous aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup ce que
la société trois mois au quotidien toi
ce lycée la presse féminine c'est quand
tu rentres chez toi sur les réseaux
sociaux tu dis waouh elle a plus de
l'ail que moi parce que l appel de
cellulite moi si je fais un zoom de mon
bourrelets mais on va me bloquer ou
signalé tu vois moi pendant très
longtemps je suis né maurice donc ça
allait je me cacher les vannes derrière
en bonnet derrière des 22es je suis là
grosse j'ai un spectacle s'appelle fat
and furious le film s'appelle forces
vives les gros on va s'en souvenir
ensemble
j'en ai fait une force pour pas que ça
ma tête mais en vrai c'est une très dure
quand tu rentres chez toi avec toute la
journée anta dia tu sors du lot est
différente et originale c'est super
c'est cool sur un métier artistique mais
je pense à tous ces gens qui sont justes
dans la vraie vie dans un vrai quotidien
qui sont pas dans les bonnes cases et et
qu'ils rentrent chez eux et moi je
savais que j'arrivais de rentrer chez
moi il met ensuite à toute la journée on
m'a dit que je sortais du look gt
original que j'étais pas comme les
autres et quand tu rentres chez toi qui
dis bah alors je vais aller sur les
réseaux
ah bah non je sais pas c'est pas bien
fait de pas être comme les autres et tu
vois personne qui te ressemble c'est
horrible tu vois je referme le magazine
et après tu dis bon bah allez c'est pas
grave je me détendre
netflix ou un film en vod et là tu vois
un signe sur les meufs qui sont pas des
vraiment qu'on connaît moi toutes les
comédies en france que j'ai pu voir même
ailleurs tu vois c'est des meufs qui se
retrouvent à l'apéro qui volent des
shots et qui dit tu t'es pas épilée tout
le bad mois on n'a jamais fait ça avec
mes copines tu en as faim c'est pas
méchant mais on se sent pas représenté
moi en tout cas je me sens pas
représenté et j'ai toute une génération
derrière moi qui ne se sent pas
représenté
[Musique]